[sighs]
Good morning, folks.
I was going to do a little bit of server
maintenance today, but the uh Boom sites
are down.
They're apparently getting
dodosed by the Middle East. That's cool.
There are a few things we could do
today.
I do sort of wonder about the uh state
based stuff for Pupper 5.
Maybe I should just sort of go through a
few things.
Return to that cell
and then explore.
Then you track newly encountered cells,
improve trajectories.
Is the chat working? It didn't turn on,
did it?
I don't know if my chat turned on.
Okay. Well, the fact that this works,
the fact that this actually works is
essentially proof um of the state
setbased
method.
Hello, vault.
How's it going?
going to figure out something to do with
inferno.
Focus on waves for a bit.
Aren't waves insta solved though, dude?
I thought the waves get solved in like
two minutes.
Hey Robin,
hardest waves were insta solving.
But vault, I was seeing it getting to
Jads quite consistently
from the uh the branch that I had and
like getting to Zuck. It seemed to me
that the hard part was figuring out Jads
and Zuck because it's really difficult
to have a non-exloitable reward.
on Nvidia GPUs
from my MacBook.
So, your Mac is just slow, Robin. You
can talk to Vault. He's got metal stuff,
but like
no matter what you do, that chip is just
slow. It's not just a matter of like
writing custom code for it. It's a
matter of Apple's hardware being
complete overpriced dog [ __ ]
You can get it faster than defaults if
you want to maintain an extra 8,000
lines. You can ask Vault about that.
But their um their low-level language is
actually just CUDA but worse.
So,
we have to get easier. Model has more
capacity for bosses.
I don't think it's about capacity, bolt.
I think it's mostly the reward function
being screwy and then our um
our curriculum method being pretty weak.
I'm also not entirely convinced that
there isn't something screwy with um the
shield because it gets just sniped by
Zuck once in a while.
Yeah. So, Robin, like here's the thing
that you do. If you can't just buy a
desktop,
then what you do is, and I do think I
might put a CPU backend, like a a better
native CPU backend, so it's easier to at
least like run the models that were
trained on CPU. I think that's a
reasonable thing to do. Um,
but then this is what you do. You go
here. Okay.
37 cents an hour for 5090s, 30 cents an
hour for 4090s,
and if you're on a really a tight
budget, 13 cents an hour for 5080s.
You don't need these chips up here. This
is the whole arbitrage of RL, right?
is that you can use these chips and
they're just as fast.
Even my Mac learns it quickly to
healers.
It's funny that your Mac learns it
quickly.
It might just need more fiddling with
them. I don't know. Vault
Yeah, I think Robin that the reasonable
thing for the laptop users would be I
think it is technically possible for us
to just reuse our exact same CUDA code
pretty much on CPU if we do it smart and
like only add a few hundred extra total
lines. Um, I think we can basically wrap
the same C code into CUDA if we're smart
about it.
That might be worth doing, but that's
kind of like um it's sort of secondary
to push the push the science because
it's already a pretty low barrier to
just have a damn GPU.
Um, I'm thinking about puffer five a
little vault.
What if we just wrote 5.0 in a day?
That'd be kind of cool, wouldn't it?
I mean, that's what I'm kind of
thinking. Don't I kind of just deserve
um
don't I deserve an easy like an easy
breakthrough at this point with all the
stuff I've done? I think like
the cosmos owes me um
one easy breakthrough. No.
What do you expect from 5?
Um,
I don't know. The light of God
illuminating our ignorance
and solving all problems
instantaneously.
Nah, we're not doing that, dude. We have
legit stuff here.
It's a lot less necessary when you don't
have 40,000 lines of AI ported stuff
vault. Like you can kind of just play it
and see if it works.
I don't know, Vault. I know lots of very
heavily tested projects that are just
total crap. I mean, that doesn't mean
the tests themselves are bad, but the
thing I dislike about um unit level
tests is they make it very difficult to
refactor your code, and it tends to lock
you into a shitty overbuilt architecture
when really you should just be moving
stuff around very frequently.
I mean, it really strongly depends,
right? Like, well, if you were going to
try to one to one uh an existing
Runescape engine, like having a port
that re like having a test that plays a
specific number of actions and then
checks the exact state and outcome of
everything to see if things match, like
that's a good idea, right? But then
having function by function test for
stuff is like
Guacamole end.
You're making an end where you whack
puffer fish.
What are you doing?
messages. They all drop messages. I
think it's reream filtering like rate
limiting [ __ ]
I can keep the YouTube chat up on the
sides.
I think it's reream filtering like rate
limiting [ __ ]
Next damn topic.
Why does it do that?
Stupid YouTube menu as well doesn't give
me like good options for anything.
What about for multi- aent M? Like
I guess that's still fine.
That's tough.
I guess we do for single agent first
I don't think you understand how [ __ ]
this menu is.
Like there isn't a menu for any of that
crap.
Yeah. So, it's the multistreaming thing
that's a pain vault.
Like, cuz you have to go through a
multistream.
It's a pain. I actually briefly streamed
some games. Not under my uh my main
account obviously, but it was fun. Back
when I thought Topper was going to be
more just game dependent.
I'm getting too hung up on the multi-
aent thing. Well, maybe there's a way I
can think about this first.
Are you just screwed in a multi- aent
sim case?
I think it'll still make sense in multi-
aent.
Okay, just not get too hung up. Let's
just solve the problems in front of us.
First three law forms.
That was quick. Congrats.
The problem is that a lot of real work
is just it's very tough and slow. Like
at the moment, what I'm doing is I'm
kind of thinking about how I want to
play with this environment code so that
um it's efficient to get and set the
state of it uh in one mem copy. And then
I'm going to try to slowly thread this
into an initial
state setbased learning implementation.
We're really not putting that that much
effort, Quinn, other than just X and a
little bit of outreach and then mostly
inbound.
Nope, not associated with Turbo Puffer.
Um, it's kind of funny that there just
so happened to be two tech startups
about Fast Puffer.
Purely coincidence.
They're cool though.
Looks like they do cool stuff.
I'm just trying out some stuff for five
guess.
Yeah, I literally have to Google these
acronyms when um it's mostly companies
that are doing RL and having a hard time
of it because all the tools suck.
Okay, let's figure out how we're going
to redo some of this stuff cuz this end
is a mess.
Okay, I have some ideas for this
suppose.
Yeah, making up acronyms is not the same
as solving problems.
BAS like their acronyms even more than
this silly. Like the scientists mostly
make up acronyms because they like to
like
they like to turn their papers into
words or whatever, you know?
He's like, "Oh yeah, we call our method
disco. Yeah, we managed to like stuff
the name of it into a funny word.
Yeah. I mean, this is the people that
are saying it's so so hard to like it's
just they're mostly just idiots.
It's like the bar is you have to dig for
it.
a lot of robotics Quinn, but I don't
think that's going to be the most
important one at all long term.
that's like saying the most heavy users
are ma of math of math are like Excel
spreadsheet users or something. It's
like stupid baby mode RL for stupid
babies.
roll by any chance?
I saw it.
Wait, are you the author?
Where's the actual paper? Why do I just
get like garbage all the time?
Well, somebody has it in C, which is
kind of funny.
So,
I mean, in my mind, this is just like
the reason that this works in my mind
for um
Yeah, the reason that this works
for language models is because they're
using stupid baby mode RL for stupid
babies.
like nothing based on evolution should
be remotely as fast.
Um like if you have RL without a value
function, you're not really doing RL.
How can you know what the paper talks
about so fast? Cuz I saw it on uh
Twitter before and I just needed to
refresh myself. I know it's like um it's
evolution with uh low rank
perturbations.
And the problem is like, okay, low rank
kind of guides perturbation, sure, but
like that's still a very weak learning
signal.
trying different low rank. Yeah, but
like evolution is just a very weak
learning signal compared to RL, right?
Like RL is not just like try different
weights, roll them out and see.
Evolution strategy should also be like
disgustingly
uh memory intensive.
It's kind of ridiculous. If that's
faster, like
the base implementation's probably
garbage.
It's actually not highly parallel though
is the thing, right? because it's
multiple data, multiple instruction.
So it's actually not like the
parallelism is not ideal for hardware.
It's very very high memory pressure.
Like why vault? You just
you just solve breakout in 4 seconds.
You just kind of shove it in 4 seconds,
you know.
No, Jess, this is um I'm adapting this
thing. I'm simplifying and adapting this
to try out state setbased methods. This
is preamble setup for puffer 5.
a just worthless.
>> No, but they're not going to solve the
types of problems I care about.
They'll do different [ __ ] But the thing
is that these companies are burning
infinite money pretending that these
stupid things are going to solve all the
problems and they're just obviously not.
So massively lying gets you massively
[ __ ] you.
Pretty simple.
um just the the grid code like there a
whole bunch of ideas going on in the
mazes for features that we don't
actually use and they're confusing me
because the state stuff is going to be
confusing enough as is. So, I'm going to
strip it down to just have the code
that's needed for the actual end visits
used. And I need to strip it so that
it's fast. Uh, it's formatted nicely to
be able to efficiently set and get
states.
And then I'm going to have to hook that
into the ve so that you can do it
vectorized. And then I have to do the
algorithm section.
want to get early selfplay merge this
weekend. Sounds good. Spencer, I'm
starting a little bit on puffer five.
Just a bit.
I was going to do server mate today, but
um a bunch is getting dodoed, so I can't
chest.
Um
I think it's your chess is not going to
be able to be a super early user of it
because I have to figure out multi- aent
with this thing, which is going to be
tricky. I think for the specific multi-
aent of your case, it's actually not
that bad and I should be able to just
have it work, but we're going to have to
see.
team sport type stuff? Not since high
school. I kind of just run and lift,
man.
Uh yeah, the Abuntu website is down.
Apparently, it's some Middle Eastern
DOS. I don't [ __ ] know.
Input volume is low.
I haven't found a good spot for the mic
now. I mean, I This is about as much as
I can mic it up here.
I just have the mic like over here
because otherwise I have to stick it in
my face in this frame.
Oh, apparently that's a task.
100 mil magic XP.
Oh yeah. Vault, did you see um like the
top 10 people on leagues? It was
literally just waiting room for whatever
random event that they were missing for
the last 30 points in typical Jagex
fashion.
200 mil. Oh, you just get it passively
from magic, man.
This is like, I don't know, 3 mil magic
XP an hour just from the transmute
relic.
So, I figure I'll just sit here, do 200
mil mining.
it'll probably be like a 100 hours, but
like realistically that means click it a
grand total of 200 times.
So, I can easily do that by the end of
the league.
And then I get free bone shards for 50
mil prayer
without having to touch anything else.
Just transmuting a bunch of ore will
give me uh 200 mil magic.
full dragon helm and visg being his
last.
Uh,
that's funny. Most of the people it was
literally just a random event. Like
there were several posts of people just
waiting for a piece of the mime outfit
or whatever.
The thing is that they rush they rush
everything so quickly that just
probability is you're going to be
missing one random event with very high
likelihood.
Yeah, I was literally carrying a a Guam
leaf for like 30 hours to for um until I
randomly got a jackal event.
It's really dumb. They made like pretty
much every individual random event is 30
points.
And then they also they made it so you
literally cannot get all of the points.
Um you literally can't get all the
global points if you don't select a raid
region
on a rand. That was for lamping uh
lamping hunter.
Yeah, it was genies and uh books to
lamp. You had to lamp Hunter all the
way. Was it to No, 27. I think it was
higher.
Yeah, it was lamping Hunter. I remember.
You can kind of force spawn them, but it
was still ridiculous.
logistics. We haven't done logistics
Liberty. That is definitely an area
where this would make sense though.
Yeah, it's um it's there's more to it
obviously than that.
You kind of want like an iterative
interactive problem.
Five minutes training we solve a whack a
puffer.
Have you considered that the question is
why we are whacking puffers?
Uh, that's not true. Liberty, like
one-step problems are not typically a
good fit for RL.
RL is magic, but don't it's not
everything on its own.
We're going to see what this whacka
puffer end is.
It's so funny cuz like I can see all the
things I'm doing incorrectly while I'm
editing this and I just don't have the
uh the mental drive to like do it
correctly right now. It's very
irritating.
Need like slightly better sleep, better
exercise. I don't know.
Still kind of burnt, I guess.
rough couple weeks. Well, it's expected,
Luke. I finished the release and I just
like
everything's just burnt out. Those are a
lot a lot of work leading up to release.
I was kind of just spending energy I
didn't have.
I actually have gotten completely out of
cardio shape doing um the puffer for
release.
Like I pretty much just burnt out all
the drive I had for normally for uh for
running.
Not great.
probably that's going to be the fix is
just to like step back for a few days
properly and start doing more uh more
exercise again
time off. I mean the last few weeks Luke
but sometimes it's just enough work that
it takes more than that.
can't just like take a week or week,
week and a half, two weeks even off and
like be back.
Like the work for Puffer 4 was just
brutally taxing.
I basically just burnt out all of the
drive that lets me normally get stuff
done. It always comes back, but it
always takes longer to come back than I
would like.
Yeah, pretty much. Luke, I kind of just
grinded the thing for
almost two years straight.
That was a ton of work.
Yeah, stuff just isn't clicking today. I
don't know.
Well, we'll see if I have it in me to at
least just get this end cleaned up
reasonably
and then I can just have a short day
today.
like if I can at least get this end so
that it's trainable with the original 40
code um but it's nicely state setable
then at least that I basically just
wanted to have a start on puffer five
right so I have a starting point because
that'll make it easier to pick up if
I've started
No, I'm not touching the cuda today,
Liberty. I don't have the mental
capacity for that.
Um, there's really not much point in
starting their liberty though cuz none
of the ends are going to be compatible
if I do that.
It just doesn't help that a lot of this
code kind of sucks.
I've gotten way better since now since I
wrote this, but I just don't have the
capacity today to like
There's one other project, Jess, that
might work. Um,
I think this is going to be the main
one.
So like in my mind and I maybe I even
will make this an explicit end.
They're kind of two types of exploration
problems.
right? You have some sort of maze like
this.
Okay, like this is this is a sparse
exploration problem.
Uh this can't be solved with
statebased stuff alone when this gets
big. But then imagine that you take this
and then you just chain onto this
another maze,
I don't know. How the [ __ ] do you draw a
maze reasonably?
You just start drawing lines and it kind
of looks like a maze, right?
Yeah.
Okay. So, when you chain these two
problems together,
this is kind of where you get the state
space, the state set exploration
is that you get to start from here and
you get to decide automatically that you
should start from here.
So, this is this is uh this thing here.
This is X,
but then this whole thing here
is also X.
So,
you need to be able to reduce both of
these
It's literally a one-step problem,
right? I'm not surprised that this works
on your uh
1650.
it's a wacka puff.
Funny.
Is it playable? Can I click the puffers?
Basically, puffer aim trainer.
Actually, puffer aim trainer would be a
good idea.
There are definitely other research
areas that I'm like interested in though
I think I'm going to approach them via
simulation.
um biological and then material science
sim are going to be the most two the two
most likelies
though today it's like I can't even
think about stuff man it's like I'm
trying to think through this just like
thick haze ish.
I'm probably just going to keep the
stream relatively short today, clean
this up as much as I feel like I can,
and then just spend some time walking
outside.
That would be better.
I think I'm just going to review this PR
and then call it actually. Like I
thought it would get better if I just
sat down and started working on it and
it usually does, but today there's just
there's nothing here. I like I just
can't think at all.
Um, that NPR looked quite simple though
to review.
And now I've just screwed up all my
windows.
I literally don't even know how to get
this [ __ ] back. Where? Where the [ __ ]
Oh,
Looks like not
okay. I'm just going to go walk then. I
don't know what else to do today. If I
feel better, I'll come back. I'll see
you in the afternoon. I would like to
get this thing done. It's actually a
quite simple piece of work, but I just
can't today. H
I guess I was I thought I was back to uh
capacity before. I have been always
takes